[Music]
hi mysteryrecaft here today i'm going to
explain an american science fiction
action film called john carter spoilers
ahead watch out and take care
the movie starts on a strange planet
called barsum the planet consists of
three major kingdoms called the helium
the zodanga and the tharks
helium and zodanga have been at war for
centuries in the beginning of the movie
we see the army of helium in blue capes
battling the army of zodanga in red
capes the general of zodanga named sab
than is approached by three men who
claim to be messengers of god called
thurn
the thurn's leader matai shang gives him
a mysterious blue weapon and tells him
that he has been chosen by the goddess
to receive it the therns have decided to
help zodenga in the war
they possess the control over a
mysterious blue light called the ninth
ray which makes them stronger than other
living creatures on barsum
we cut to new york city in 1881 a man
named edgar is summoned by his uncle
named john carter to new york city when
edgar drops at the station he is greeted
by john's butler who takes him to john's
estate as it turns out jon is a wealthy
man and a former confederate army
captain john's lawyer sadly informs
edgar of john's sudden death john has
left all of his vast wealth to edgar the
lawyer then takes a surprised edgar to
john's mausoleum where his body is being
preserved but strangely the door of the
mausoleum only opens from the inside
later the lawyer hands edgar a personal
diary of jon which jon wanted only edgar
to read when the lawyer leaves he begins
to read it it begins by mentioning that
edgar was the only one who believed
john's wild stories when he was little
so it only feels right to tell this
story to edgar the story starts in
arizona after the civil war john carter
is a former captain in the confederate
army who currently looks for gold in
caves powell is a union colonel who
wants john to help his u.s cavalry
soldiers against the apache so he
abducts him and tries drafting him as a
soldier however jon doesn't want to
fight as a soldier anymore after several
failed attempts of running away he
manages to escape by knocking a guard
out and stealing the colonel's horse the
colonel and his men pursue him not far
away they come across a mounted apache
warband the colonel and the men get into
a shootout with the people jon tries
running away amidst the chaos but the
colonel gets injured in the fight
he helps the colonel out of pity and
brings him to a nearby cave the cave is
new to jon as he has never come here in
search of gold he goes inside lights a
match and is beyond surprised to see
lots of gold embedded on the roof of the
cave however just then a man behind him
appears out of nowhere the man is one of
the thrones we saw in the beginning of
the movie the colonel alerts jon who
gets into a fight with the strange man
he shoots the man making him fall to the
ground when jon goes near him he hears
the man say barsoom while looking at a
strange medallion in his hands
john picks up the medallion and repeats
the word barsoom
suddenly a bright blue light flashes out
of the locket when jon opens his eyes
again he is in a strange desert he gets
up and tries walking but falls in every
step it seems as though he can float in
mid-air confused he practices walking in
the new environment as he walks he
reaches a hill nearby where he sees
several eggs hatching just then a large
group of green creatures with six limbs
appear riding on massive animals the
leader attacks him making jon take a
huge leap the rest start firing at jon
but stop when their leader asks them to
the creature speaks in a different
language and introduces himself as tas
tarkas jon introduces himself as john
carter from virginia but the creatures
decipher that his name is virginia
tarkus asks jon to jump as he did before
but he denies and attacks him the
creatures injure jon and hold him
hostage as they talk we get to know that
their kind is called tharks elsewhere on
the same planet the princess of the city
of helium deja practices presenting a
weapon she has designed to her father
the king of helium helium is at war with
another city called the zodanga and is
about to lose because of thurns being on
zodanga's side deja has figured out the
secret of the ninth ray used by the
zodanga to fight the war
however when she shows her weapon to the
king a man secretly causes a malfunction
causing it to explode the king of
zodanga sab than wants to marry deja for
the war to end but she is extremely
against it if sabthan marries her he
will be the prince of helium and will
have the power to rule all of barsum
meanwhile the tharks take jon to their
city and put him with the newly born
infants at night a female farc named
sola feeds jon a liquid after which he
can understand the language of the
tharks the following day the tharks
order jon to jump high in front of
everyone
jon notices that the medallion is with
tarkus and without it he cannot go back
home
just then two battleships appear in the
sky the helium and the zodanga are
battling each other
the war is entertainment to the tharks
who bet on who will win
we see princess deja fighting in the
ships she tries to control the ship but
falls off of it in the process
jon using his newfound jumping powers
saves the princess
the tharks start cheering for jon who is
now fighting the zodangas soldiers along
with deja
jon manages to change the course of the
fight making the helium win but their
ship crashes as well
deja and jon are with the tharks tarkas
is impressed by john's abilities and
makes him his right hand man
jon is reluctant to the idea but doesn't
disagree
at night deja and john talk and deja
reveals to jon that they are on mars
which is called barsoom in their
language
john is surprised and doesn't believe
her he tells her that he is from earth
deja finds that hard to believe too
because of his thicker bone density and
the planet's low gravity carter has
incredible strength and can leap high
deja then takes him to the thark's
temple where no humans are allowed to go
she hopes that the temple has a way to
know how people can travel through
worlds as john did
the kind female thark sola follows along
behind them begging them to stop
deja shows jon the statue of the goddess
isis and reads some markings engraved in
it however the three of them are soon
arrested by the tharks and sentenced to
death for entering the temple tarkus
asks everyone to leave him alone with
the prisoners in the cell in order to
cut jon's hands off when they are alone
he reveals that he is sola's father and
doesn't want them to die at the hands of
the tharks he hands jon his medallion
and asks him to go to the river is to
solve the mystery of the goddess isis
and get back to his world when the
tharks look into the room after some
time they see that tarkus has betrayed
them tarkus's enemy talheu takes charge
and declares himself the new leader then
we see jon deja and sola heading for the
river is
deja is leading the way however sola
tells jon that she is leading them
towards the city of helium instead of
the river jon confronts her about it and
it turns out that she was taking him to
her city to use him as a soldier in the
war disappointed jon asks sola to lead
the way and leaves the princess there
deja insists that she only did it
because she doesn't want to marry sabzan
he asks her to accompany him to the
river with no other way out she agrees
the three sail through the river of is
and reach a massive inverted pyramid jon
and deja go on top of it and see a
strange blue energy forming on the
ground deja realizes that this is the
power of the ninth ray that she had made
her weapon from they also realized that
carter's appearance on mars is likely
due to the transmission of a copy of
himself from earth to mars with the help
of the ninth ray
just then an army of war hoons
approaches led by matai shang the leader
of the thurns jon bravely tells deja and
sola to run away and fights the army of
warhoons himself
the king of helium sends his army to
jon's aid who defeats the warhoons and
saves them they take an injured john to
helium deja reaches her home and meets
her father she is surprised to see the
king of zodanga sabthan there he has
come with no weapon or soldiers to ask
deja to marry him and end the war deja
doesn't have any other way to stop the
war so she reluctantly agrees to marry
him in the following scene we see jon
resting in a chamber in a helium palace
a soldier appointed by deja fetches him
and secretly takes him to her chamber
deja asks jon to go back to his home
using the medallion when the guards
enter her chamber jon disappears deja
thinks that he went back to the earth
but jon is actually hiding from the
soldiers when they leave he tries going
outside but is soon caught by mata shang
jon is surprised by matai shang's
ability to change into any creature
around him the whole city is preparing
for the wedding of sabthan and deja
matai shang binds jon to himself with
the help of a technology developed by
the ninth ray jon is unable to move his
body to his will matai shang seems to be
controlling him with his wrist device
mantai shang then reveals to him that
sabthan is planning to kill deja and
invade helium after the marriage the
thern took his side in the war because
sabthan was the easiest to manipulate
but matai shang's real aim is to rule
all of barsum through sabthan
matai shang is about to kill jon when an
alien dog jon had befriended earlier
comes to his rescue it bites off matai
shang's wrist device letting jon free he
hurries to a flying craft and flies away
to stop deja from marrying sabthan
however jon doesn't know how to control
the aircraft and crash lands near the
thark's territory they hold him captive
with a beaten targus
talheu who is now the leader of the
tharks puts jon and tarkus with massive
beasts called the white apes jon somehow
manages to capture the apes in front of
the whole thark population he then
invites talhaju to fight him and defeats
him in one go everyone cheers for jon
who is now the new leader of the tharks
he then persuades them to help him fight
the zodanga the army of tharks and jon
make their way to deja and sabthan's
wedding ceremony jon reaches there just
in time to stop the wedding seeing him
sab than tries to kill deja but jon
stops him just in time a war between the
soldiers of the two cities erupts again
however the tharks are on the side of
helium now the zodanga soon loses but
matai shang manages to escape with jon's
medallion jon plans to live on mars as
deja's husband so he doesn't bother to
look for the medallion he and deja get
married and the crowd cheers for them he
is now the prince of helium the
following morning jon and deja are on a
balcony deja leaves john outside and
goes into the room when matai shang
appears jon tries to fight him but he
manages to use the medallion to send jon
back to earth when jon wakes up he is
covered in dust and his beard has grown
long he is in the same cave and looks
toward colonel powell to see his remains
suggesting that a long time has passed
on earth while he was on mars he looks
around for a medallion but doesn't find
it he has no way to go back
the gold embedded in the cave makes him
wealthy he knows that there are more
medallions on earth he starts a mining
corporation and searches for the
medallion for the next 10 years until
one day he finally finds one on a site
john is delighted but he knows that the
therns have been keeping an eye on him
all this time his body on the earth must
be protected when he goes to mars
because any harm on it will cause him to
die on both planets that is why his
mausoleum only opens from the inside he
had orchestrated his death to return
back to mars john writes in the diary
that he wants edgar to protect his
mausoleum from the thurns in turn of the
wealth edgar is in shock after reading
the diary he goes out to the mausoleum
and tries opening it with a secret
password which turns out to be ned the
name jon called edgar when he was a kid
as the doors to the mausoleum open a
thirn approaches edgar he had been
spying on edgar waiting to kill jon
however before he can harm edgar someone
from behind knocks him out edgar is
beyond surprised to see his uncle in
front of him jon takes the thurn's
medallion as it turns out he had never
found the medallion all this including
his death was faked to attract a thirn
and acquire his medallion jon then asks
edgar to protect his mausoleum from now
on and goes inside of it he lies on the
bed with the medallion and begins the
chant that will take him back to mars
again
bar soon subscribe for more videos like
this turn on notifications and leave a
like to help the channel out thank you
for watching